EMILY FORTUNA: Joining us now
is Soniya Jobanputra, a product
manager at Google,
who is here to give us
the 411 on those
sleek new phones.
Hi, Soniya.
SONIYA JOBANPUTRA: Hi, Emily.
EMILY FORTUNA: So your team
has been amazingly busy
these past few months
getting out this new Pixel
to the lineup.
What inspired you to
create this phone?
SONIYA JOBANPUTRA: Yeah, well,
we set out to do Pixel in 2016.
We really set out to
do something different,
to really bring radically
helpful hardware
to our consumers.
And we thought we could
do that by bringing
the power of hardware,
software, and AI together.
And we still believe that.
That's still our mission
with these devices.
But with the benefit
of three years,
we've been able to finally
bring a phone that's
more affordable to more people.
And what we've managed
to do is essentially
improve our capabilities from
a manufacturing standpoint,
a hardware design and software
standpoint, and
three, we've just
understood our users better
over the last three years.
Starting with the third one,
understanding our users.
By understanding our users,
we can pick which pillars
and which parts of the product
are most important to our users
and focus on those
areas to design
phones that give users what they
need in a really optimized way.
On the second two,
we really have
year over year improved
our manufacturing.
When we started out,
we had other people
building our phones for us.
We are now a full-contract
manufacturer.
We design and build
our own devices,
which means we've
come a tremendous way
from a manufacturing standpoint.
Finally, on the
engineering side,
just last year we
ended up acquiring
a huge and talented engineering
team in Taiwan from HTC.
That team has been the
lead on these devices.
And they have brought years
and years of experience,
in conjunction with our Chicago
design team and our Mountain
View design team,
to come together
to build this new Pixel 3a
device, the more affordable
Pixel device at $399.
EMILY FORTUNA:
That's super cool.
I am personally very excited
to see a new phone come out
with a headphone jack
and a great camera.
What are your three favorite
features on this new phone?
SONIYA JOBANPUTRA:
Yeah, well, let's talk
about that headphone jack.
We debated on this
headphone jack.
But we really felt that
consumers at this price point,
in this price tier,
really needed flexibility.
And that's what that
headphone jack gives you.
We still support digital audio,
and it is the ultimate way
to consume your audio, right?
You can either use our
USB-C adapter on the bottom
or you can use
Bluetooth headphones.
And digital audio is incredible.
But a lot of people
have headphones,
and we didn't need to create
anymore e-waste in the world.
So, we've decided to put a
3.5-millimeter headset jack
in so that people could use the
accessories that they already
had available to them.
Now, my top three.
Let's start with the
camera, because I
think that's everybody's
top for Pixel, in general.
And Pixel 3a is incredible.
It shares the same
camera experiences
that you get on your Pixel
3 device, minus group selfie
mode.
But, in general, you
get all the great stuff,
starting with Night
Sight, which lets you take
incredible images in low light.
My favorite is taking
pictures of my kids
when they're sleeping because
they sleep in the most
awkward positions, but
you would be surprised
at the detail you can get.
You can catch their bedspread,
their little stuffies,
and that's without turning
any lights on in the room.
It is truly incredible.
On top of Night Sight, of
course you get Portrait Mode.
So you can take those
incredible selfies
with that bouquet effect,
with that beautiful blurred
background.
And we have a depth
editor, so you
can change and
adjust that just to
how you want to
see that picture.
We also have Photobooth.
Again, I'll say, savior
when you have kids.
You just turn on the
Photobooth and it
captures the picture when
they're both facing the camera
and smiling.
That is a rare split-second
event anywhere.
And Photobooth captures
it every single time.
And that's also available
on the Pixel 3a.
So, by far, the most
incredible thing on this device
is this camera.
It's amazing.
And finally, it has
unlimited storage,
just like our Pixel 3 devices--
with high quality, though.
My second favorite has
to be Google Assistant.
Google Assistant is awesome.
It saves time and
effort all day long.
You just have to talk to
the phone to set reminders,
get directions.
It's super quick and easy.
And when you're
on the go, that's
what you need, something that's
quick and easy and reliable.
Finally, it also
has Call Screen.
I don't know about you, but
I get a lot of spam calls.
Call Screen is a savior.
And with the power of Google
Assistant and Call Screen,
I only pick up calls that
matter now, which is amazing.
And the bonus?
You get to waste a little bit
of time of that spammer's time
as they try to call
you and have to deal
with your little
automated message.
So I really appreciate
Call Screen.
And then my final one
has to be battery life.
We heard this loud and
clear from our research
that battery life is an issue.
And we all feel this anxiety
of, like, oh no, I have 20%.
Am I going to get
through the day?
We wanted to eliminate
battery anxiety,
and I think we've done a
fabulous job on these devices.
One, we beefed up the batteries,
so they're just bigger.
On top of that, these both
support Adaptive Battery,
which we introduced on our
Pixel devices earlier this year.
And that just makes the
battery a little bit smarter
around how it's using the
power and extending it.
And so these devices both get
up to 30 hours of battery life
on a full charge.
On top of that, we put
a fast charger in box.
That's an 18-watt
charger in the box.
You can charge this
bad boy for 15 minutes
and get seven hours
of battery life,
while you're, like, getting
ready to get out the door.
Charge it and you have the
whole night available to you.
It's pretty fantastic.
So those would have
to be my top three.
EMILY FORTUNA: That is
quite an impressive list.
SONIYA JOBANPUTRA: Thanks.
EMILY FORTUNA: I'd be curious
to learn a little bit more
about the camera itself.
Can you tell me some
more of the specifics
on how it's able to create
all these cool effects?
SONIYA JOBANPUTRA:
Yeah, absolutely.
So it starts with the hardware.
The hardware that we've
picked for these cameras
is not mid-tier.
It is premium hardware.
In fact, the imager on the
rear is the exact same imager
that we use on our
premium devices.
The front imager is also
the same normal field
of view imager that we use
for our premium devices.
So we started with
really great raw images.
From there, our magical
software team took over.
They are phenomenal.
And they really were put
to task on this phone
because, as you may
know, the phone has not
the same type of processing
power as our premium phones.
It has the Snapdragon 670 in
it, versus the 800 series that
sits in our premium phones.
So we've really condensed
their processing power,
and they were still
able to deliver.
They optimized every
last aspect of the camera
features to get them
to work on here.
Each individual feature
was revisited by the team
to not only optimize
the algorithms,
but to optimize the
overall experience to work
on these particular devices.
And they did it.
They did a phenomenal job of
delivering those low software
features.
EMILY FORTUNA: Thank
you so much, Soniya,
for coming to talk to us
about the Pixel 3a and 3a XL.
SONIYA JOBANPUTRA: Thanks
for having me, Emily.
It was really exciting
to talk about them.
[MUSIC PLAYING]